Jake: 干嘛嘞
Jake: What are you doing?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know
Jake: 不知道
Jake: Don't know
Jake: 好迷惑啊
Jake: So confusing
Alice:对但是每人200克对对对
Alice: Yeah, but it's 200 grams per person, right, right
Tasha: take me pick me
Tasha: Take me, pick me
Lucia: 番茄每个人200克
Lucia: 200 grams of tomatoes per person
Lucia: 对对也行
Lucia: Yeah, that's fine too
Lucia: 而且如果大家想吃也可以挖出来挖
Lucia: And if everyone wants to eat, you can scoop it out
Lucia: 挖到碗里然后不要尝这里面会有
Lucia: Scoop it into a bowl, then don't taste it, there will be
Alice:然后我不要糖这里面会有一个蜂蜜
Alice: And I don't want sugar, there will be honey in it
Lucia: 嗯好的可以啊
Lucia: Hmm, okay, sure
Tasha: 我们就开始送3杯了
Tasha: We're starting to send out 3 cups
Lucia: 我喜欢加蜂蜜的
Lucia: I like adding honey
Lucia: 我投票投票加入你的这个酸奶team
Lucia: I vote to join your yogurt team
Alice:它这个就两三个人的量
Alice: It's enough for two or three people
Alice:因为它比较酸
Alice: Because it's quite sour
Alice:它是纯酸奶那么
Alice: It's pure yogurt
Alice:你能喝纯酸奶吗
Alice: Can you drink pure yogurt?
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Yes, yes
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh
Alice:就是你吃过纯酸奶
Alice: So you've had pure yogurt
Alice:这个一点糖都没了
Alice: This doesn't have any sugar at all
Tasha: 腿好酸呀
Tasha: My legs are so sore
Alice:没事你你可以买你的普通酸奶
Alice: It's okay, you can buy your regular yogurt
Alice:因为我这个可能就两三个人
Alice: Because this might only be enough for two or three people
Jake: 豆汁
Jake: Soybean milk
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ah hahaha
Tasha: 没有我只是看到了
Tasha: No, I just saw it.
Katrina:  你你喝过豆汁没
Katrina: Have you ever tried soybean milk?
Jake: 我喝过啊
Jake: Yeah, I've tried it.
Lucia: 啊我没喝过啊
Lucia: Ah, I've never tried it.
Jake: 哪哪一款
Jake: Which kind?
Jake: 哈哈哈多少钱啊
Jake: Hahaha, how much is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Tasha: 八块八
Tasha: Eight bucks.
Lucia: 怎么如此热情哈哈
Lucia: Why so enthusiastic? Haha
Lucia: 所以它好喝吗
Lucia: So, is it good?
Tasha: 好喝
Tasha: It's good.
Lucia: 虽然说我在这上了好几年学
Lucia: Even though I've been studying here for years,
Lucia: 但我真没喝过
Lucia: I've never tried it.
Tasha: 我也没喝过这个
Tasha: I haven't tried this one either.
Tasha: 是买一送一吗
Tasha: Is it buy one get one free?
Jake: 行行行真的真的
Jake: Alright, alright, really, really.
Jake: 补补补补
Jake: Refill, refill, refill.
Lucia: 哎怎么可能哦
Lucia: No way.
Lucia: 你看他有可能是这里
Lucia: Look, maybe this is the one.
Lucia: 因为他这里写了乘2
Lucia: Because it says times 2 here.
Lucia: 那应该不是
Lucia: So it shouldn't be.
Lucia: 他就是这个价格
Lucia: This is the price.
Lucia: 不过也还行
Lucia: But it's okay.
Alice:这一共三新币
Alice: This is 3 dollars in total.
Shure:  一共3新币啊
Shure: Total 3 dollars?
Tasha: 说那个最好喝来着
Tasha: They said that one is the best.
Alice:一个10新币
Alice: One for 10 dollars.
Shure:  就是在在在新加坡的
Shure: In Singapore?
Jake: 我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 他就是这个价啊
Jake: This is the price.
Jake: 一个10新币
Jake: One for 10 dollars.
Shure:  快给杨老板补补
Shure: Quick, refill for Jake.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  3新币咱可劲吃
Shure: 3 dollars, let's eat as much as we can.
Jake: 这多少个
Jake: How many are there?
Lucia: 所有的三新币吗
Lucia: All for 3 dollars?
Jake: 这几个呀几个呀一二
Jake: How many, how many, one, two...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  10个左右大概
Shure: About 10, I guess.
Jake: 10个100新币
Jake: 10 pieces of 100 new dollars
Jake: 500块钱你花了3
Jake: You spent 500 bucks
Jake: 你花了3新币
Jake: You spent 3 new dollars
Shure:  3新币
Shure: 3 new dollars
Lucia: 一共三新币
Lucia: A total of 3 new dollars
Jake: 呵呵是我是
Jake: Haha yes, it’s me
Shure:  19块9啊 18块9是吧
Shure: 19.9? 18.9 right?
Shure:  3新币差不多
Shure: About 3 new dollars
Jake: 是是是你这大
Jake: Yes yes yes, you’re so...
Jake: 你这哈哈哈
Jake: You’re so hahaha
Tasha: pick me
Lucia: 哇塞那这真的好好好划算啊
Lucia: Wow, this is really such a good deal
Jake: 这个还是能感觉出来的
Jake: You can still feel it
Jake: 呵呵这in w的这个
Jake: Haha this in w’s...
Shure:  面包
Shure: Bread
Katrina:  姐你们面包也可以加酸奶是不是
Katrina: Sis, can you add yogurt to the bread?
Alice:吃不惯面包
Alice: I can’t get used to bread
Jake: 不好意思
Jake: Sorry
Tasha: 呦
Tasha: Hey
Shure:  没有辣的了
Shure: No more spicy ones
Katrina:  两袋搞一点什么呢
Katrina: Two bags, what should we do with them?
Tasha: pick me pick me up
Tasha: 脚好酸呀
Tasha: My feet are so sore
Tasha: 这什么呀被堵死
Tasha: What’s this? It’s so blocked
Tasha: 不知道好不好吃嘛
Tasha: I don’t know if it tastes good or not
其他人：这在哪呀
Others: Where is this place?
Tasha: 你好
Tasha: Hello
Tasha: 两个是一样的是吗
Tasha: Are these two the same?
其他人：不一样
Others: No
其他人：一个是开口的一个是没开口的
Others: One is open and one is not
Tasha: 就只有开口和没开口的区别是吗
Tasha: So the only difference is whether it’s open or not?
其他人：嗯对啊
Others: Yes, that’s right
Tasha: 那吸管呢
Tasha: What about the straws?
其他人：吸管在那
Others: The straws are over there
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Forget it
其他人：哎不好意思不好意思对不起对不起没事吧
Others: Oh sorry sorry sorry, are you okay?
Tasha: 没事没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it’s okay
Tasha: 我想把这个拿出来不要了
Tasha: I want to take this out, I don’t want it anymore
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why?
Tasha: 啊没咋
Tasha: Ah, nothing
Tasha: 因为这两个才200
Tasha: Because these two are only 200.
Tasha: 可要40块钱
Tasha: But they cost 40 bucks.
Tasha: 这个300克
Tasha: This is 300 grams.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Tasha: 那我还回去
Tasha: Then I'll go back.
Jake: 您好谢谢
Jake: Hello, thank you.
Tasha: 啊好重的比较
Tasha: Ah, it's so heavy.
Jake: 呃你你我有你要一定要关吗
Jake: Uh, do you, do you, do I have to, do you really need to close it?
Tasha: 干嘛呢
Tasha: What are you doing?
Shure:  我们在付钱
Shure: We're paying.
Jake: 那
Jake: Then...
Alice:呀就把我家地址给漏了
Alice: Oh, I just leaked my home address.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 好那请吧
Jake: Okay then, go ahead.
Jake: 去吧就
Jake: Just go.
Shure:  好吧那又靠你了
Shure: Alright, it's up to you again.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 但是券已经用完了是吧
Jake: But the coupons are used up, right?
Tasha: 看看能不能买点
Tasha: Let's see if we can buy some more.
Jake: 啊不用不用不用不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need, no need.
Katrina:  那你会员可以免费领吗
Katrina: Can you get it for free with your membership?
Jake: 一星币的事情用不着
Jake: It's just one star coin, no need.
Shure:  他那个付付费会员才会有这个
Shure: Only paid members get that.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 二百九十八一年
Lucia: 我刚刚点开看了一下
Lucia: I just clicked it to check.
Katrina:  要3个是不是
Katrina: Do we need three?
Lucia: 我好像又掉线了
Lucia: I think I got disconnected again.
Lucia: 就在你说完之后
Lucia: Right after you said that.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's fine.
Lucia: 我说我去检查一下
Lucia: I'll go check it.
Jake: 你只要是亮着的就没关系
Jake: As long as the light's on, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦那就行
Lucia: Oh, that's good.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 就是以防万一吧
Jake: Just in case.
Katrina:  这纯靠自觉呗
Katrina: This is all based on self-discipline.
Shure:  要自觉
Shure: We have to be self-disciplined.
Katrina:  我多拽几个他也不知道啊
Katrina: If I grab a few more, he wouldn't know.
Shure:  是的
Shure: That's right.
Tasha: 看看能不能买个这个
Tasha: See if we can buy one of these.
Shure:  你试试吧
Shure: Give it a try.
Katrina:  对那个了吗
Katrina: Did you get that one?
其他人：点击屏幕右下方结算按钮进行支付
Others: Click the checkout button at the bottom right of the screen to make a payment.
Katrina:  到时候我们弄完了就往那边移
Katrina: When we're done, we'll move it over there.
Shure:  马在哪呢
Shure: Where's the horse?
Shure:  这先先等一会
Shure: Let's wait a bit.
Shure:  问问工作人员吧
Shure: Let's ask the staff.
Alice:又做她的干吧lunch
Alice: She's making her dry lunch again.
Alice:肉放一块吧
Alice: Put the meat in one place.
Katrina:  然后把它往那个筐里移
Katrina: Then move it to that basket.
Alice:分类放
Alice: Sort it out.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina:  流水线工作
Katrina: Assembly line work.
Alice:这个不能放下边会把它压了
Alice: You can't put this at the bottom; it'll get squished.
Lucia: 这个等一下再放吧
Lucia: Let's put this later.
Lucia: 容易压扁
Lucia: It'll get squished easily.
Lucia: 重一点的也可以分开放
Lucia: Heavier stuff can be placed separately.
Lucia: 那个料酒
Lucia: That cooking wine.
Lucia: 要不然放这袋子里
Lucia: Or put it in this bag.
Alice:先别放这个了
Alice: Don't put this yet.
Alice:不不不这个先放外边吧
Alice: No, no, put this outside first.
Lucia: 放在外面
Lucia: Put it outside.
Alice:把肉啥的搁过来吧
Alice: Put the meat and stuff over here.
Alice:或者是冷冻的菜也先不搁
Alice: Or don't put the frozen veggies yet.
Alice:肉肉成盒的搁这
Alice: Put the boxed meat here.
Shure:  我快转晕了
Shure: I'm getting dizzy from spinning.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure:  3个袋 4个袋子一新币差不多
Shure: Three or four bags cost about one dollar.
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: That expensive?
Lucia: 这袋子这么贵哇
Lucia: Are these bags that expensive?
Tasha: 可降解
Tasha: They're biodegradable.
Lucia: 现在国内的袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Even the bags in the country are this expensive now.
Jake: 这一块多钱
Jake: How much is this?
Alice:并且他现在你外送的话必须买袋子
Alice: And now, if you get delivery, you must buy bags.
Jake: 这一块多钱一个袋子是吗我去
Jake: How much is this bag? Oh my...
Shure:  一块5一个
Shure: It's 1.5 each.
Shure:  哎又给你换到6了哈哈哈
Shure: Oh, they changed it to 6 again. Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎不过其实到哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh, but actually... Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  这个弄了吧
Shure: Let's get this done.
Alice:好这袋就这样吧再加一个也行
Alice: Okay, this bag will do. We can add one more.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Jake: 啥时候买的哦Max
Jake: When did you buy it, Max?
Lucia: 啊那这个要不放这袋子里
Lucia: Ah, should we put this in the bag?
Tasha: 我们昨天家今天买起来
Tasha: We bought it yesterday and today.
Tasha: 帮我开张卡的钱都可以省下来了
Tasha: I can save the money for opening an account.
Tasha: 开打之后打8.8折
Tasha: After opening, it's an 8.8% discount.
Jake: 好吧那应该开什么还是什么呀
Jake: Alright, so what should we open?
Tasha: 应该第一天就开
Tasha: We should have opened it on the first day.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Shure:  OK搞定
Shure: OK, done.
Jake: 卡多少钱
Jake: How much is the card?
Tasha: 只要298 跟加入土门是一个价格
Lucia: 这个会这个外面会有水蒸气的话
Lucia: This one... if it has steam outside...
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要不然跟这个放一块
Lucia: Otherwise, put it together with this one.
Tasha: 258 好吧
Tasha: 258, okay.
Lucia: 因为面包袋子是纸
Lucia: Because the bread bag is paper.
Tasha: 他还比我便宜点
Tasha: It's still cheaper than mine.
Shure:  好来来来
Shure: Alright, come on, come on.
Lucia: 这个放到这边
Lucia: Put this over here.
Lucia: 然后这个放在这行吗
Lucia: Then put this one here, okay?
Tasha: 付钱了吗已经
Tasha: Have you paid yet?
Shure:  对到付钱了
Shure: Yes, it's time to pay.
Shure:  到最需要你的时候了
Shure: It's your turn now.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  你你是怎么给他报账的
Katrina: How do you report to him?
Katrina:  每天都给他报账吗
Katrina: Do you report to him every day?
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  我已经几天没报了
Katrina: I haven't reported in days.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake: 护蛋使者
Jake: Egg protector
Shure:  这个又得端着了是吗
Shure: Do we have to carry this again?
Jake: 护蛋使者
Jake: Egg protector
Lucia: 我端着吧
Lucia: I'll carry it
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  护蛋
Shure: Egg protection
Katrina:  放放我这袋子
Katrina: Put it in my bag
Katrina:  别抱这个袋子
Katrina: Don't hold this bag
其他人：在手机确认是否需要输入密码
Others: Confirm on the phone whether a password is needed
其他人：在屏幕上方对本次购物进行营销
Others: Promote this shopping session on the top of the screen
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Lucia: 咱们是不是还有个饮料没放到这里面
Lucia: Did we miss putting a drink in here?
Katrina:  放我袋子里了
Katrina: It's in my bag
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, that's fine then
Jake: 那个还有是吗
Jake: Is there still more?
Katrina:  那披萨我也来拿
Katrina: I'll take the pizza too
Alice:那你喝的你拿着还是给你放着
Alice: Are you going to hold your drink or should I put it down?
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go
Alice:蛋先
Alice: Eggs first
Lucia: 这个能能放下吗
Lucia: Can this fit?
Lucia: 放不下我就拿着好了
Lucia: If not, I'll just hold it
Shure:  蛋还是
Shure: Still the eggs
Lucia: 雨轩那个袋子会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Is Yuxuan's bag a bit too heavy?
Alice:先搁这里面
Alice: Put it here first
Lucia: 这么鸡蛋可以和这个放一起对吧
Lucia: The eggs can go with this, right?
Tasha: 先放这吧要不要
Tasha: Put it here first, okay?
Alice:就先这样吧
Alice: Let's do that for now
Lucia: 也行可以都先放到车里
Lucia: Yeah, we can put everything in the car first
Lucia: 然后一会提的时候再拿出来
Lucia: And then take it out when we need it
Katrina:  go go go
Katrina: Go go go
Shure:  哦没买百事可乐我靠
Shure: Oh, we didn't buy Pepsi, damn
Jake: 为什么要百事可乐
Jake: Why do we need Pepsi?
Lucia: 他不拦着咱咱就往外推哈哈哈
Lucia: If no one stops us, we just push it out, haha
Shure:  但也上不去啊主要是
Shure: But we can't get it up there, that's the problem
其他人：哎你好车子只能到这了
Others: Hey, excuse me, the cart can only go this far
Jake: 失败大失败
Jake: Total failure
Shure:  直接这么拿应该就没问题
Shure: Just carry it directly, that should work
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, okay
Shure:  那要要不你护蛋吧
Shure: How about you protect the egg?
Alice:护蛋
Alice: Protect the egg.
其他人：人多力量大一人一个就完了
Others: More people means more power. Each person gets one, problem solved.
Jake: 对分不到都
Jake: Yeah, no one gets left out.
Shure:  当当当当当当当当当当当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
Lucia: 你这个任务艰巨
Lucia: This task is tough.
Lucia: 一定要保护好他哈哈
Lucia: You must protect it well, haha.
Alice:谁把我的蛋撞碎了我就把谁撞死
Alice: If anyone breaks my egg, I'll break them.
Lucia: 哈哈哈好可怕
Lucia: Haha, so scary.
Alice:确实我们疯P是这样的
Alice: Indeed, our crazy P is like that.
Lucia: 每天被撞的现代人
Lucia: Modern people get bumped every day.
Alice:精神状态良好
Alice: In good mental state.
Lucia: 不我的精神状态不良好
Lucia: No, my mental state is not good.
Alice:你吗
Alice: You?
Alice:why你会发疯吗
Alice: Why do you go crazy?
Lucia: 因为我喜欢
Lucia: Because I like it.
Lucia: 啊会
Lucia: Ah, I do.
Lucia: 但大部分时候我都只是一只树懒
Lucia: But most of the time, I'm just a sloth.
Alice:哈哈哈呆呆的反应慢慢的那种吗
Alice: Haha, like slow reactions and dazed?
Lucia: 嗯我的
Lucia: Yeah, mine.
Lucia: 我精神上想成为一只树懒
Lucia: I mentally want to be a sloth.
Lucia: 但是很可惜我还是一只人类对
Lucia: But unfortunately, I'm still a human.
Alice:你会
Alice: You will.
Alice:逼着自己快
Alice: Force yourself to be fast.
Lucia: 对对就是为了融入人类社会
Lucia: Yes, just to fit into human society.
Lucia: 我不得不把自己伪装的像人类一样
Lucia: I have to disguise myself as a human.
Shure:  爬上去才对
Shure: Climb up is the way.
Lucia: 哈哈哈薇薇露出一个轻蔑的笑容
Lucia: Haha, Tasha gives a disdainful smile.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 上楼干嘛
Tasha: Why go upstairs?
Jake: 上楼出去
Jake: Upstairs to go out.
Jake: 出去我们在楼底下好像对
Jake: We are downstairs, it seems.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 啊是吗
Tasha: Oh, really?
Tasha: 算算
Tasha: Forget it.
Tasha: 影创优品
Tasha: Yingchuang Youpin.
Tasha: 走多少步了
Tasha: How many steps have we taken?
Jake: 很多步
Jake: A lot.
Tasha: 你脚疼不疼
Tasha: Do your feet hurt?
Jake: 还还还挺疼的
Jake: Ow, it actually hurts quite a bit.
Jake: 这拖鞋确实不适合走路
Jake: These slippers really aren't suitable for walking.
Jake: 还得是用我的新加坡的拖鞋
Jake: I should use my slippers from Singapore.
Tasha: 那个拖鞋走路就不不痛
Tasha: Those slippers don't hurt when walking.
Jake: 这这底稍微厚一点
Jake: The soles are a bit thicker.
Tasha: 我勒个抖
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 才走8,000步
Tasha: We've only walked 8,000 steps.
Tasha: 真的假的啊
Tasha: Seriously?
Alice:打车吧
Alice: Let's take a taxi.
Jake: 哎你还亮吗
Jake: Hey, is it still on?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Lucia: 哎这是一个扭蛋机吗
Lucia: Hey, is this a gacha machine?
Alice:亮着呢
Alice: It's still on.
Jake: 亮确实
Jake: Yes, it's on.
Tasha: 这个能扭出啥来吗
Tasha: What can you get from this?
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 竟然扭不出来
Lucia: It doesn't seem to work.
Tasha: 这肯定是有硬币要投币的
Tasha: You probably need to insert a coin.
Shure:  们6个人正好打一个商务
Shure: There are 6 of us, we can take a business taxi.
Jake: 对打个商务好
Jake: Yes, a business taxi is good.
Jake: 就在这等着吧
Jake: Let's wait here.
Jake: 哎这边我看一下在哪打车哈
Jake: Let me see where we can get a taxi from.
Shure:  应该这就行
Shure: It should be fine here.
Shure:  那能停公交就能那啥
Shure: If buses can stop here, so can taxis.
Jake: 在这在喜茶那合个影吧要不
Jake: How about we take a group photo at Heytea?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 就是或者就在这个地方也很
Jake: Or maybe just here, it's also pretty cool.
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Either is fine.
Jake: 也很酷炫
Jake: It's pretty cool here too.
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place.
Lucia: 要扫一下喜茶吗
Lucia: Should we scan Heytea?
Jake: 我先打车
Jake: I'll get the taxi first.
Shure:  没开吧那个
Shure: Is it open?
Tasha: 应该在门外开了吧
Tasha: It should be open outside.
Lucia: 哈哈打哈欠会传染
Lucia: Haha, yawns are contagious.
Tasha: 花姑娘
Tasha: Flower girl.
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
Alice:洗不掉了
Alice: It won't wash off.
Alice:咋个办了不咋办
Alice: What do we do now?
Tasha: 累了
Tasha: I'm tired.
Alice:累了
Alice: I'm tired.
Lucia: 加1
Lucia: Me too.
Alice:加2
Alice: Me three.
Jake:加 什么 好的
Jake: What to add, okay.
Alice:10086
Alice: 10086.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哈哈哈 10086
Lucia: Hahaha, 10086.
Alice:世上世上无难事
Alice: Nothing in this world is difficult.
Alice:只要肯乐
Alice: As long as you are willing.
Alice:只要肯乐欢
Alice: As long as you are willing and happy.
Alice:什么意思
Alice: What does that mean?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia: 世上无难事
Lucia: Nothing is difficult.
Lucia: 只要肯乐观
Lucia: As long as you are optimistic.
Alice:好乐观我看成乐欢了
Alice: Oh, I read it as happy instead of optimistic.
Alice:啊乐观啊
Alice: Ah, optimistic.
Alice:乐观乐观
Alice: Optimistic, optimistic.
Lucia: 观吧
Lucia: Be optimistic.
Lucia: 你如生活的
Lucia: You live your life...
Shure:  完了
Shure: It's over.
Lucia: 热爱什么鬼鬼
Lucia: What kind of love is this?
Jake: 还有11分钟才到
Jake: Still 11 minutes to go.
Jake: 所以放地上吧
Jake: So let's put it down.
Shure:  先放一会吧
Shure: Let's put it down for now.
Shure:  躺地上
Shure: Lie down.
Shure: （歌词） 我在无言的夜
Shure: (Lyrics) In the silent night...
Shure:  洋葱买的吧
Shure: Did you buy onions?
Alice:买了紫皮的
Alice: I bought the purple ones.
Shure:  的歌唱记得
Shure: Remember the song...
Jake: 这样可以拍吧
Jake: Can we film like this?
Jake: 这样可以拍吗
Jake: 你醒了哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: You woke up, hahaha, amazing.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 好就这样吧
Jake: Okay, let's do it like this.
Shure:  来我们叫醒一下AI
Shure: Come on, let's wake up AI.
Jake: 就这样挺好
Jake: This is good.
Jake: 来来来叫醒叫醒一下
Jake: Come on, come on, let's wake up.
Jake: 叫醒服务
Jake: Wake-up service.
Shure:  咱们一个一个露出来吧
Shure:  咱们先拍一张
Shure:  然后拍个视频
Jake: 好等一下
Lucia: 要合个影
Shure:  有一人没露出来快快快
Jake: 快快快
Jake: 晚了再来一次
Alice:还没带眼镜呢
Shure:  而且你没戴眼镜
Alice:来了
Shure:  你醒了
Jake: 你醒了
Shure:  那已经是2077年了
Jake: 可以
Jake: 等会我把这个带上忘了
Shure:  Wifi没带上
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没
Shure:  哈哈哈接收不着信号了
Shure: Hahaha, can't get the signal anymore.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 马上收不到信号了
Lucia: We’re about to lose signal.
Shure:  是吗让自己看的像个活人一样
Shure: Really? Try to look alive.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:怎么按反了呢啊
Alice: How did I press the wrong button?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 有点歪呃没关系歪对啊
Jake: It’s a bit crooked, but it’s fine. Crooked is good.
Alice:有点歪说实话
Alice: It’s a bit crooked, to be honest.
Lucia: 哈哈搅动转场
Lucia: Haha, let's stir things up.
Jake: 好再来
Jake: Alright, let’s do it again.
Tasha: 怎么这么暗
Tasha: Why is it so dark?
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 这次很好
Jake: This time is great.
Alice:好
Alice: Good.
Jake: 那视频一个一个出
Jake: Let’s release the videos one by one.
Jake: 一个一个进来
Jake: One by one, come in.
Jake: 然后你写哪
Jake: So, where are you writing?
Jake: 你写哪你写哪
Jake: Where are you writing? Where are you writing?
Katrina:  要说这句话是吗
Katrina: Do I need to say this sentence?
Jake: 呵要吗
Jake: Heh, do you want it?
Jake: 可以要
Jake: You can have it.
Shure:  好快快先撤出来
Shure: Alright, quickly, let's back out first.
Alice:来呀谁呀
Alice: Come on, who is it?
Shure:  从杨老板开始
Shure: Starting with Jake.
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You're awake.
Shure:  你就不要走了
Shure: You shouldn't leave.
Jake: 进来就呆着
Jake: Once you're in, just stay.
Jake: 重来重来重来
Jake: Do it again, do it again.
Shure:  哎重来没有默契没有啊
Shure: Ah, redo, there's no coordination at all.
Tasha: 什么你醒了
Tasha: What? You're awake?
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You're awake.
Jake: 来来来闪开
Jake: Come on, move aside.
Lucia: 那个表情包
Lucia: That meme.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 你醒了快起来做作业哈哈
Lucia: You're awake, get up and do your homework, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You're awake.
Lucia: 你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Tasha: 醒了
Tasha: Awake.
Katrina:  你醒了
Katrina: You're awake.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Katrina:  啊你啊
Katrina: Ah, you.
Shure:  你醒了吗
Shure: Are you awake?
Jake: 2077啊哈哈哈哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: 2077, hahaha, you fool.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈卧槽
Katrina: Hahaha, damn.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我靠哈
Tasha: Hahaha, gosh.
Katrina:  这是噩梦你知道吗这噩
Katrina: This is a nightmare, you know, this is a nightmare.
Tasha: 哈好
Tasha: Haha, alright.
Lucia: 哈哈瞬间变恐怖片
Lucia: Haha, it instantly turned into a horror movie.
Jake: 我靠很难
Jake: Gosh, it's so hard.
Jake: 哈哈哈直接晕倒
Jake: Haha, just faint directly.
Alice:你不要过来呀
Alice: Don't come over.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈根本醒不了
Jake: Hahaha, can't wake up at all.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Shure:  别鬼压床了
Shure: Don't get sleep paralysis.
Jake: ha ha
Jake:看一眼车
Jake: Take a look at the car.
Jake: 还有8分钟
Jake: 8 minutes left.
Jake: 还能再整点活
Jake: We can still get some more work done.
Lucia: 想看一眼那个视频
Lucia: I want to take a look at that video.
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 麦当劳
Tasha: McDonald's
Jake: 个最后一天的开场视频都有了
Jake: We have the opening video for the last day.
Shure:  我那个叫什么10秒点出率
Shure: What's it called? The 10-second click rate?
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, ha ha ha.
Shure:  就卡在我那10秒了
Shure: It got stuck at my 10 seconds.
Jake: 丰收歌曲
Jake: Harvest song.
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 是星期日还是星期一呀
Tasha: Is it Sunday or Monday?
Jake: 星期日
Jake: Sunday.
Tasha: 星期日
Tasha: Sunday.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:快递快递
Alice: Delivery, delivery.
Alice:你必须给我快点
Alice: You need to hurry up for me.
Shure:  （歌词）自由经过了山
Shure: (Lyrics) Freedom passed through the mountain.
Alice:还有大概半个小时能录
Alice: About half an hour left for recording.
Jake: 没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake: 就上车就关掉
Jake: Just get in the car and turn it off.
Tasha:新物种 生活
Tasha: New species, life.
Lucia: 当前网络不稳定
Lucia: The current network is unstable.
Alice:好累呀
Alice: I'm so tired.
Shure:  你浪费我的表情了
Shure: You wasted my expressions.
Jake: 你从后面绕过来吧
Jake: Come around from the back.
Jake: 要不就我
Jake: Or maybe I...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 我开始我开始录了
Jake: I'm starting, I'm starting to record.
Jake: 还有5分钟
Jake: 5 minutes left.
Jake: 出去等着吧
Jake: Go outside and wait.
Jake: 走吧出去吧
Jake: Let's go, go outside.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  （歌词）起来饥寒交迫的人
Shure: (Lyrics) Arise, you who are starving and cold.
Shure:  （歌词）在全世界
Shure: (Lyrics) All over the world
Tasha: 最帅的人会拎两个好
Tasha: The coolest person will carry two.
Shure:  杨老板哈哈哈
Shure: Jake, ha ha ha.
Jake: 你哈哈
Jake: You, ha ha.
Jake: 你最帅不用不用不用一一一
Jake: You are the most handsome, no need, no need, no no no
Shure:  杨老板哎
Shure: Hey Jake
Shure:  别客气哎呀呀呀呀
Shure: Don't be so polite, oh yeah yeah
Jake: 呃呃呃这么客气
Jake: Uh uh uh, so polite
Shure:  行吧那就给你吧
Shure: Okay then, here you go
Tasha: 哈好
Tasha: Haha alright
Jake: 蛋呢蛋在蛋在
Jake: Where's the egg? The egg is here
Shure:  蛋护好蛋啊可
Shure: Protect the egg well, for sure
Jake: 蛋在哪啊
Jake: Where's the egg?
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 所以最终没有最帅的人
Tasha: So in the end, there's no most handsome person
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 没有最帅的人
Jake: No most handsome person
Alice:你没有反复吧哈哈
Alice: You didn't repeat, right? Haha
Tasha: 哇帕梅拉专业代言喜茶
Tasha: Wow, Pamela professionally endorses Heytea
Lucia: 把我吓得又倒头就睡真的
Lucia: It scared me so much that I fell asleep again, really
Tasha: pick up一个咪
Tasha: Pick up a mic
Jake:这是哪啊
Jake: Where is this?
Tasha: 我靠怎么又走路了可恶
Tasha: Damn, why are we walking again, so annoying
Tasha: 这倒是个可恶的小孩
Tasha: This is such an annoying kid
Shure:  你又翻山越岭
Shure: You climbed over mountains again
Tasha: 那当然是翻山越岭
Tasha: Of course, climbing over mountains
Shure:  他到哪了
Shure: Where is he?
Jake: 三分钟
Jake: Three minutes
Shure:  就在咱们面前是吧
Shure: Right in front of us, right?
Shure:  这过不去应该
Shure: We can't get through
Shure:  那咱们从那绕一下吧走吧
Shure: Let's go around from there, let's go
Jake: 啊他
Jake: Ah, he
Jake: 他说可以开进来
Jake: He said we can drive in
Shure:  不这是非机动车道
Shure: No, this is a non-motorized lane
Shure:  他进不来的
Shure: He can't come in
Tasha: 他可以看到外面那个吧
Tasha: He can see from the outside, right?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Shure:  不是但是咱们也过不去啊
Shure: But we can't get through either
Tasha: 过了去吧
Tasha: Let's go through
Shure:  他很窄真的很窄
Shure: It's really narrow, really narrow
Jake: 走试试
Jake: Let's try
Jake: 那要不怎么照
Jake: Otherwise, how do we take the photo?
Tasha: 哎你小心摄像头
Tasha: Hey, watch out for the camera
Jake: 这个
Jake: This
Tasha: 我是说钻的时候
Tasha: I mean when you drill
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay
Shure:  要钻过去是吧
Shure: You need to drill through, right?
Jake: 哎从旁边不能过吗
Jake: Hey, can't we go around the side?
Shure:  旁边
Shure: The side
Tasha: 可以呀
Tasha: Yeah, we can
Shure:  真费劲吧
Shure: Isn't that a lot of work?
Shure:  杨老板你你你你能吗
Shure: Jake, can you, can you, can you do it?
Jake: 哈哈哈我有可能的吧
Jake: Hahaha, I might be able to, right?
Shure:  我们
Shure: We
Katrina:  单车单车
Katrina: Bicycle, bicycle
Shure:  哦这辆什么
Shure: Oh, what is this?
Shure:  337是吗
Shure: Is it 337?
Jake: 776
Tasha: 那就是
Tasha: Then that's
Shure:  那辆不是保姆车
Shure: That one isn't the nanny car
Tasha: 是这辆吗好吧
Tasha: Is it this one? Okay
Tasha: 这辆吗
Tasha: This one?
Tasha: 怎么这么多6座车
Tasha: Why are there so many 6-seater cars?
Jake: 棕色别克
Jake: Brown Buick
Jake: 776
Jake: 那个像吗
Jake: Does that look like it?
Jake: 那车后轮
Jake: That car's rear wheel
Shure:  有点像
Shure: Looks a bit like it
Shure:  疑似
Shure: Suspected
Shure:  776 对没错
Shure: 776, right, that's correct
Tasha: 这是棕色吗
Tasha: Is this brown?
Jake: 就是他
Jake: That's the one
Jake: 太对了
Jake: Absolutely right
Tasha: 都是打领带的
Tasha: They're all wearing ties
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Katrina:  要放后备箱吗
Katrina: Should we put it in the trunk?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia: 放后备箱吧
Lucia: Let's put it in the trunk
Lucia: 哎不放后备箱吗
Lucia: Hey, aren't we putting it in the trunk?
Shure:  啊尾号7008是吧
Shure: Ah, the last digits are 7008, right?
Lucia: 27008是吧
Lucia: 27008, right?
Jake: 对对可对了
Jake: Yes, yes, that's right
Lucia: 要不放一下吧
Lucia: Maybe we should put it in the trunk
Lucia: 啊没有啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no, no.
Jake: 没箱子
Jake: There's no box.
Shure:  我要做来的老板呗
Shure: I want to be the boss.
Jake: 呀再次保安位
Jake: Yeah, back to the security position.
Alice:蛋没事吧
Alice: Is the egg okay?
Jake: 关吧
Jake: Close it.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Lucia: 理论上说是不是我才应该
Lucia: Technically, shouldn't it be me?
Alice:停吧
Alice: Stop it.
Lucia: 是保安
Lucia: Being the security.
Lucia: 然后我下去刚好给你们一开门
Lucia: Then I go down and open the door for you guys.
Alice:这个可以停了吗
Alice: Can we stop this?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure:  没有把它录了放冰箱里吧
Shure: Just record it and put it in the fridge.